hello believe nation I'm going to
continue the series today it's a test
pilot series for us where we take the
best content and utilize have enjoyed
the most from the past month on the
channel of all the videos from the past
month taking the best parts that you
guys resonated the most with and
combining them into one big mashup of
the best entrepreneur motivation vol 4 I
hope you enjoy and as you watch if
somebody says something that really
inspires and motivates you or resonates
with you please leave in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be motivated as well talking
about past and future and excessive
emphasis on past and future in your life
yes of course you need to have it
there's nothing wrong with having a
certain intention of what you want to
achieve take steps towards it it's a
it's part of living here in this
dimension you can't just say I'm never
going to plan anything anymore just take
life as it comes
well some people try to do that but
they're not that happy either after a
while so it then your life will get very
diffused and so to have an intention to
have to make a plan perfectly fine what
you either a short-term plan like I got
to meet you tomorrow at 4 o'clock how
would you ever meet anybody if we didn't
have time and and future and a practical
level of course it's needed the question
is whether future takes over your mind
being able to use it for practical
purposes it will cause great but I call
it clock time is fine but psychological
time is when the future takes over your
mind and your entire soul patterns are
geared only towards future and you treat
the present moment as either just a
means to an end because enables you to
get to the next one you're always
reaching out so to speak internally to
the next yet never quite here always
looking for some fulfillment there so
you can never embrace the fullness of
now or you make them now into even an
enemy some people are always unhappy you
we all know some one or two people like
that three we all who are wherever they
are they're complaining is never quite
right wherever they are or whoever they
are with after a little while they're
very uncomfortable again there should be
somewhere else you know the bumper
sticker that you see in some car scene
give up various versions of it says I'd
rather be golfing and then another one
says I'd rather be fishing I'd rather be
this I'd rather be there when I visited
to the spiritual teacher Ram Das who
lives in Hawaii he has a bumper sticker
on Obama dust was the person who in the
70s wrote the book B and now that anyway
he has a bumper sticker on his car that
says I'd rather be here now so and and
then you realize you can actually you
can still pursue whatever an intense
where you want to get to a plan I call
that it's a bit like a journey your life
is it is a journey you're going you know
you want to go from here to there
whether you're going to get there we
don't know maybe on the way you'll
branch out to somewhere else but at
least you have a certain direction it's
good to have some direction in your life
but while you are traveling if the that
your destination takes up most of your
attention and you're continuously
focusing on there you miss all the
journey really you can't enjoy the
journey anymore and most of your life is
the journey the arriving is relatively
rare the wedding
and a few more graduation but so those
moments are not that fine feel between
so the rest is the journey and if you
can't enjoy the journey which means the
step you are taking at this moment it's
really the most important thing yes of
course you know you're going that way
but this step is still to be enjoyed
because that's ultimately your whole
life consists of the step you are taking
at this moment that is never anything
else I mentioned courage and I would I
would like to say something else about
that finding courage and the leaders and
in you who will become leaders courage
is the most important important of all
the virtues because without courage you
can't practice any other virtue
consistently you see you can't be
consistently kind or fair or humane or
generous not without courage because if
you don't have it sooner or later you'll
stop and say ah if the threat is too
much the the difficulty is too too high
they the challenge is is too great you
know I believe that self-love is very
important if you read my work you know
I'm always talking about loving oneself
I never trust anybody who tells me he or
she loves me as the person doesn't love
herself or himself there's an African
saying which is be careful when a naked
person offers you a shirt
I mean if he had something cover himself
first right so I like to look at
self-love it is very important that it
comes from within that you have a sense
of yourself so that when you walk into
an office
you don't go alone bring your people
with you bring everybody who has loved
you with you say grandma come on let's
do great grandpa you've been dead all
this time come on list of I have to go
in here and have an interview come on
auntie come on my friends come let's go
and when you walk in people don't know
what it is about you they can't take
their eyes off you you may not be cute
in the given sense you may not be
dashing model size in that particular
sense you may not be any of those things
but they can't take their eyes off you
and they say of you in this incredible
wave which I don't understand they say I
don't know but she has charisma you know
what you have is all those people around
you so think of that any time you have
anything to do bring everybody with you
that you can remember who has loved you
and then you have that sense of having
been paid for and when you walk in
people will say man I think you're
overqualified without sounding like
everybody else am you know Sancho he was
real Don Quixote by fan attention Watson
main most important thing of one you got
to get rid of dust if you got down what
you're doing it's not gonna work
you're now saying and the way to do that
is you have a plan cuz if you got a plan
it's not like just a pipe journey you
have a step-by-step list of things to do
to get to your goal if you don't have
that it's very hard to really have faith
in what you don't cuz sooner some pop up
is gonna look like the handle but if you
got a gang planning everything you need
to do you know one thing pop up well I
still got to do this justice and that
sorta saying will stop me you know I've
seen another thing pop low
accomplish these two things I sense that
my last obstacle only got three months
things and oh let me keep pushing pretty
soon you said you attain your goal and
then you create another but without a
game plan without a strong sense of
faith in what you're doing
it's gonna be real hard to accomplish
anything how'd you come up with the idea
that you know really focus on your core
fans um I think that's one of my like
natural inclination is just being a rap
fan like i follow artists and a lot of
times I feel like I'm a real core one of
their fans and I get upset when they
straight and try to go like dude that's
outside of you know I'm saying what I
what I [ __ ] for I understand it
because it turns for good business
sometime but I'd be like you know you
didn't have to really do that you know
and uh it seemed like they always end up
coming back yeah to what they fans love
them for so um I just thought you know
before I got in the game I like I'm
gonna be a artist that you stick to my
you really represent what I represented
the hallway towards do my best to then
try to find ways within that you know to
get the big looks and they get the
singles and again that you know turns
for good business but I never wanted to
like alienate my brand for business
always wanted to like keep it off then
it can keep it as as pure as I could
would you ever sign our deal major not
me just the structure the majors they
don't respect Talent you know I'm seeing
all these little dolls right out not
definitely months later
you at the bottom of the totem pole
go-go type man's go rap go sing and then
with talk to your manager or we talk to
the executives involved in your
situation you know of course when you
blow up they jump no date and act like
you know they don't but it's not respect
and I'm saying to me respect come first
so when I walk in the door you're not
saying I'm the executive representing
the talent I'm not the time I'm the
executive representative talent so
that's the different conversation don't
play with me you know so you know don't
talk to me like the town is
disrespectful to me
I'm at peace with what I'm doing I feel
good about what I'm waking up doing them
and about my lifestyle at one point I
wasn't proud of my lifestyle you know
I'm saying I wasn't I wasn't content
with what I was doing on a day-to-day
basis I wasn't happy with that so what
was eating then even though I'll be on
the surface cool and straight deep down
I wasn't I knew that this was the
direction of what I need to be doing now
I wake up with the feeling that I'm
throwing in the direction I'm here folk
like when I'm on this planet for I'm
doing it right rather than just LA
they're getting gangbanged a businessman
Street it's just so something so human
you know I'm doing what I'm here to do I
felt like so it feel good success to me
I say it a lot is just being able to do
what you love to do and support yourself
offer live your dream and do what you
got to do everybody so I'm successful my
offices I don't sell dope on call the
workmen are do music and I love to do it
and that's all I had to do this too many
time how how surprised are us
I'm not surprised
those you saw back that I mean I saw
some a group of people that wasn't gonna
stop and I'm not asked as best a formula
for success
I saw a group of people that came from
somewhere that you already get them to
have opportunities that I was looking at
same way I look at it we won't get these
opportunities I'm gonna make this work
you know I'm saying so I know that
failure of life you know how dare you
from how dare you fail I was a victim of
my own success and I did some ed
Sullivan's I hate on those Ed Sullivan
shows I began to realize not just there
everywhere all these shows I didn't fit
and here's what I was missing I was
missing who I was I began with a dream
of being Danny Kaye which is a very
mainstream dream
it's very middle America it's a
people-pleaser job and I dreamed a path
that was traditional commedia a disc
jockey comedian actor big success a
mainstream dream meanwhile what I really
was was an outlaw and a rebel because I
had lived there they got that kind of
life I got kicked out of three different
schools I got kicked out of the Air
Force I got kicked out of the choir I
got kicked out of the altar boys I
kicked out a cuz summer camp I got
kicked out of the Boy Scouts and I quit
school at ninth grade I had great marks
I was a smart kid but I didn't care they
didn't want teaching what I want I
didn't give you it's important in life
if you don't give you it can help you a
lot so I didn't give it and I was this
kind of I was a pot smoker when I was 13
we broke the law we broke into cars we
broke into offices we broke into
Columbia University to be broke into
stores we did all sorts of unlawful
things and I was that kind of person I
was one who swam against the tide of
what is expected and what is but the
establishment wants from us but I didn't
know that about myself because his dream
blinded me this dream was about a man
America about the path then we all
follow the middle-of-the-road
middle-class America mainstream will
dream and being Wayne while I'm sitting
there like this you know those people
that look at this stupid you know I
don't want to be in the Bunny number can
I get out of the bunny number please I
don't want to put on the uniform you
know and and and I didn't know this
dissonance was inside me and in the
period this is happening all through the
60s the counterculture was forming the
Free Speech Movement started in Berkeley
the hippies were growing into a force
and peace love power blue flower power
pot smoke and anti authorities he'd been
naming anti-authority throw over the
establishment burned down the math
building Wow ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding so I gravitated toward that
because I was that person really and and
the people I hung around with were that
way the can the musicians I knew in the
late 50s had gone through that
transition suddenly they looked
different and their music change and I'm
listening to people like the Buffalo
Springfield I'm listen to Bob Dylan
listen these people in there I realized
these artists are using their talent to
project their feelings and ideas not
just please people and I suddenly was
able to see my place and to realize I
was in the wrong place you see in 1967
the Summer of Love the peak of the
hippie movement I was 30 I was
entertaining people in my clubs who were
40 and they were at war with their kids
who were 20 there was a generation war I
was in the middle of it I was 32 2040
and I'm gonna by doing over here these
are the people that will at least
understand me and give me a chance
so it took two years I didn't go to the
mountain and come back different I
didn't do a Bobby down and they didn't
do a whatever those people who just go
away and they're back new suddenly I
took two years to change and it happened
on television so it was if I had I
denied that part of myself and finally
it came into full flower and I never
a really big success until that I
probably had 200 television appearances
by that time and I still wasn't realized
as a writer comedian as a comedian by
that I mean I hadn't let myself grow
into that and and I found out later I
was more than just a comedian well this
is interesting this is a very important
show business lesson and this is why I
always come Gary look all I am is an
instinctive actor I don't know how to do
anything else all right this is another
story about repetition and learning by
doing we we did Twelfth Night in in high
school I was playing Andrew aguecheek
and that not Fabian Fabian is a bad role
I might even been cut for my area I was
playing AG you argued Andrew aguecheek
and we had done it like most high
schools you know do it what ho I told
you did we all sounded like that except
John Gilchrist and it was a great actor
and we one day we were told by our drama
teacher that we were going to perform
scenes at every assembly for the day so
we performed these scenes three times in
six times in one day we don't have to go
to class we just had to perform these
these scenes from Shakespeare for about
300 people at a time 300 of our friends
and or enemies or the people that we you
know hope we wouldn't see at school when
we would show up because they were evil
but and so about third assembly well we
started cutting up and by the time we
got to the sixth one I had five or six
gags ass or anyway aggregate that were
absolute killer and when you know when
somebody laughs at Shakespeare in high
school you're done then you're just
you're just settled it's that's all you
want to do from then on yeah I was I was
a worthless student there anyway but
that made me even more so we want you to
play a guy called Alan whose marriages
in bits so he goes to Saudi Arabia to
try and sell the King some high-tech
virtual reality at what point do you say
I mean I mean right about the time that
all of the major studios say no way in
hell
we make this movie that dude when they
where they are so against the idea make
of the movie you know you're gonna be
you know you've got something if you
look for that thing that that that moves
you I don't know what it is
I like repetition I there's a saying
goes rapid repetition repetition keeps
me green yeah I love that saying that
decision keeps me green keeps me green
become fresh because the idea that we do
performance is over and over again you
say well doesn't that get boring or
stale but no it's in the repetition that
the creation comes that the expression
comes because I'll give you an example I
was doing Richard once not particularly
well and this show is going on and we
couldn't get this court scene with a lot
of people in it I didn't understand what
I was doing in the scene so we would
call rehearsals I would rehearse it and
stuff and we would talk about it think
about it you know like all this kind of
work with people together trying to
figure out something in the 85th
performance of Richard I had done it on
my 85th entrance
I knew the court see I understood it I I
was there I could play but not in 84 not
maybe four I was might have been getting
closer didn't realize it yeah I gave up
the ghost I guess I just gave it up and
said oh screw it it's not gonna happen
and I'll just keep going on and I found
it I would like to be someone who takes
chances I think part of the adventure of
it is to is to go into something and and
and not be afraid to screw up because
then you're reaching for something
come on why are you doing this Roy no I
mean it say it say Roy Cohn you are a
homosexual and I will proceed
systematically to destroy your
reputation and your practice and your
career I think what happens is you learn
to forgive yourself because it's you see
in the scheme of things how it is and
you say well gee you know I tried it the
worst thing as they say is not to go for
it but if you go for it and it goes you
know it's out of your hands and it's
right that all saying what any what
anyone ever says about me is really none
of my business so you know you sort of
you go and you can you hope for the best
and then you see that a lot of times you
know you things happen and you have no
control when I was younger everybody
told me not to be an actor to this day I
say that to people who come up to me and
say I'm thinking of going into acting
what do you think I say absolutely not
it's a terrible idea don't do it because
that's what everyone said to me and I
think if you're gonna make it in this
business
that is so full of rejection and
hardship you need to believe in yourself
despite what everybody you love and
Trust tells you and and it's a very
personal journey and so so that was
really helpful I think you know the
advice to stay away from this career was
really helpful in my own understanding
that it was that important that I pursue
it you know the first job I got was a
real job besides commercials and things
like that
local radio commercials and things that
kind of gave us the money Ben and I had
a joint bank account and we'd go to New
York and if you made money act then you
went into the account and the account
was only to be used if if you were going
to New York for an audition or if we
took $10 out to like play video games
and I got a line in the movie mystic
pizza and the line was mom do you want
my green stuff and literally but it was
a scene that was a big dinner table
scene Julia Roberts at the Attica
for her and and it was this old dinner
table scene and so it took us three
nights to shoot and down in Mystic
Connecticut and I was a miner so my
mother had to come with me and you know
we shot from five to five every every
night and and I just remember being so
in love with the process of film I just
and I was like this is the greatest it
was the best time I've ever had in my
life and it was you know I was like this
is amazing I want this to never ever
ever stop like I loved it but I mean we
really wrote Good Will Hunting out of
necessity I mean we just needed a job
and we and and you know as you all know
they don't really give those out here so
so it was just you know two guys who
were eager and young and had a lot of
energy and a lot of creative energy and
that's a big prep is always a big
problem with LA and New York was you
you know you'd meet these other actors
and they and it's like you're raring to
go and there's nowhere to put that
energy and so you know it can get put in
horrible places it can get put in you
know drugs and all that you know or you
can try to somehow channel it into
something that feels productive and even
if it doesn't nothing comes of it it's
still productive in the sense that
you're working even if you're getting
together in groups and doing scenes or
taking classes or trying to cobble
together a screenplay the energy is
going somewhere well we all are in the
business of storytelling I mean it's not
just exclusive for people like me who
are in the entertainment business I
think that no matter what business
you're in no matter what you're you're
selling or doing why is it certain
businesses can hover above their
competition I mean your Starbucks really
serving the best cup of coffee maybe not
I mean I like a caramel macchiato myself
but is American Express really the best
return rate on a credit card probably
not but it's the story they managed to
tell and I think that the more that we
think about that the more that we
you know sometimes you we see
commercials and we see stuff and we just
go I so you need to turn off but somehow
those people that managed to tell a
story that managed to even temporarily
move us in a certain way that we
remember we don't feel like we're being
sold we feel like we're being told
something that we can connect to so I've
always been driven by that very idea
that very notion can we help us
appreciate this early experience these
lean years these very difficult years
leading up to the ultimate prize there
is no prize out there the only prize is
this one and what do you feel and what
you want to accomplish and if you can as
you start out these what could be lean
ears or could be fat ears
I feel that I very often watch a lot of
young people sort of meander around
without any idea about why they're doing
what they're doing
I mean to want and to be ambitious and
to want to be successful is not enough
that's just desire to know what you want
to understand why you're doing it to
dedicate every breath in your body to
achieve if you feel you have something
to give if you feel that your particular
talent is worth developing is worth
caring for then there's nothing you
can't achieve and I think that when I
was beginning as an actor I was
fortunate to have gone to Julliard when
I did go study drama with a great number
of actors and actresses who were going
on to become very well-known very
quickly and I wasn't and I think the
sort of greatest lesson I came out of
about that was that comparing yourself
to other people is a real mistake I mean
my struggle wasn't any worse or less or
whatever than anyone else is it was just
mine
I think the audition process is no
different than going for a meeting as a
cinematographer or if you want to be in
any of the of the disciplines of this
industry very often the thing that
actors tend to do is I think they tend
to focus on the wrong thing so if I were
to say to you what do you think the
purpose of an audition is what was your
answer be what's the purpose of an
audition
to live truthfully in the moment very
nice most people would say to get the
fun job all right
now that is a very very very dangerous
place to start to want to get the job
now look let's face facts if you get the
job how great that's great it's icing on
the cake it's fantastic but I believe
that if actors were better willing to
adopt a philosophy that it is an
opportunity to walk into a room and to
begin a relationship that may not pay
off with that particular job sometimes
actors are so nervous and they want that
job so much or they can't pay their rent
they got to get that job well we see
that you know the director sees that so
the problem with that is that you're not
being yourself you can't be truthful in
the moment when your focus is on the
result instead of what on that day at
that moment is the beginning of a
process can I work with this actor the
directors thinking does this actor pay
attention do they listen and when I give
them direction do they actually change
anything do they take direction go that
way and if you can stand in a room and
say I may be raw I may be undeveloped I
may have no experience but I trust
myself enough and I believe in myself
enough on this day that I want to
introduce myself to this director
casting director producer assistant and
by the way be really nice to the
assistants
because no one behind that table is any
different than you everyone behind that
table is just as ambitious as you are
that director wants to be doing better
things that casting director wants to be
a director that assistant that assistant
wants to be the casting director
everybody wants to be somewhere else in
10 years just like you do so we're all
in the same boat and it's sometimes hard
to believe this no matter how rude they
might be no matter how you knows because
some of them are just there in those
kind of situations but my point is this
they're on your side because they have
to cast this thing and because people
are fundamentally lazy they'd rather be
home smoking pot and watching TV so
they want you to be good they want you
to solve their problem and too often I
think people don't realize that you have
to take the long view the short view is
I'm what this job I need this job I want
this job the long view is I have a
chance to meet someone I may admire
someone I could work with but I may not
be right for this job on this day that
has nothing to do with my talent
it could be a thousand reasons why you
don't get a job but if I'm good enough
if I stand on that stage and I show them
where my talent is on this day I walk
out that door they might look at each
other and go she's really good she's
really good she's not right for this but
she's really good and the next time they
do a film or the next time they do a
play they'll bring you back
and someday along that long road you may
get that job but it's about
relationships and it's about trusting
yourself and where you are and realizing
you are good enough for where you are
right now on that day and I believe in
the long view I'm not going to spend
much time on work and don't look shocked
it's not that I don't think it's
tremendously important because it is
we've got to accept responsibility we've
got to accept the fact that we've got to
perform and as I tell the kids all over
America today now is the best time
you'll ever have in life to get ahead
now is the most opportune time in
America that it has ever been to get
ahead here's what I say if you show up
for work on time
and stay there until the appointed
departure time if you do what they pay
you to do and then they pay you then
adios anybody anything now if you want
to raise get there a few minutes early
ask for extra things to do be cheerful
and positive and optimistic and helpful
don't goof off and try to get out of
work deliberately seek the boss to find
extra work and then I will absolutely
guarantee you a raise in short order now
your current employer might not be the
one to give you the raise but somebody
down the streets going to see what
you're doing and they're gonna say if
that's the boy I want working for me
that's the girl I want working for me
because he or she are doing more than
they're paid to do that's the way you
get a raise aw don't misunderstand you
got to work you you can't be like this
old boy down home and you're gonna find
out earlier than an awful lot of old
boys down home somebody at least they're
worth when I was down there somebody
asked him how long you've been working
for his accountant and he said ever
since they threatened to fire me so
that's about the size of it yeah but
here's what we've discovered if you got
a good self-image if you have your goals
set in life if you've got the right
mental attitude nobody has to tell you
go to work that just follows naturally
so this is what we're going to work on
and you got to have a desire to succeed
you can't just casually want the good
things in life it's got to become a
passion for you your dream has got to be
more than just an idle thoughts you got
to be willing to build a foundation
under it and that's for sure we're going
to be taking these steps and quite
obviously ladies and gentleman I believe
that these steps are what is necessary
but let me let me identify to you what
one of the major problems in America is
one of the problems as you see we have
said to people all of these things are
available we've shown in the big homes
the big cars the swimming pools the jet
set the you know that style of living
that a lot of people say yeah I'd kind
of like that then on the other side of
the ledger we have said everybody not
only can get these things but everybody
deserves these things America
a rich and affluent land and everybody
can get them then we have another
segment of society that says that crime
is caused by poverty with one segment
saying you deserve these things and you
ought to have them and another segment
saying that crime is caused by poverty
we subliminally subconsciously plan a
thought don't wait to get it go get it
right now there has never been a
definitive study that establishes any
correlation between crime and poverty
during the Great Depression the crime
rate was much lower in 1939 than it was
in 1930 at the end of a decade of the
roughest depression our country has ever
had so what we're saying is let's start
climbing some steps you see we could
draw you an elevator to the top but I'd
have to be honest and say the elevator
doesn't work you're gonna have to start
taking these steps and you're going to
have to take them one at a time but I've
discovered that people don't mind taking
the steps if you tell them where they
are
show them how many of there are and then
tell them exactly how to climb the steps
but you see you've gotta climb the steps
you can't skip them on September the
15th 1944 in Jackson Mississippi at the
YWCA at exactly 18 minutes after 8
o'clock I saw the participant anding
over by the Nickelodeon now some of you
won't know what a Nickelodeon is that's
a jukebox okay and I thought to myself
boy what I'd really like to do is I'd
like to go over there and I'd like to
grab her in my arms and I'd like to
start hugging her and kissing her right
now that's exactly what I wanted to do
but if I had she wouldn't be sitting
here is my wife of over 30 years today
because I would have skipped too many
steps
so I did something real original I
walked up to her and I said and she said
hi and the first thing you know since it
was a dance that we were little YWCA
dance and we were dancing and I got a
telephone number that night and we had a
lot of telephone calls and and then one
day I said hey we ought to be going out
and she said okay so we had a date then
we had an oven in another one and then
you know it was about two years and two
months and 11 days and one hour later
that she became my very own but we took
some steps along the way I don't care a
bright you are in school you cannot move
from 2 times 2 equals 4 into analytical
geometry you got to take some steps now
the mistake a lot of people make is they
get on one step and sit there you know
that's not what I'm talking about either
what I'm talking about is taking these
steps and then you will get these number
of years ago our majors my executive
assistants got a phone call from a lady
in Birmingham Alabama and then of the
conversation she said Zig she said I
believe this woman thinks she's got an
impossible problem but I believe you can
solve that problem her with her in just
a few minutes if you will spend that
time with her I said well Laurie tell
her to meet me backstage I'll get there
about 10 minutes early they my schedule
was such that was about all I had well I
got there and I was on the backstage
behind the curtain on one side she
spotted me from the other side and if
she walked across the stage I had never
seen as much anger in a human being in
my life as I saw in her she almost
started crying when she saw me she said
oh I'm just so glad to see you I got
this horrible job I hate it I hate
everything about it I hate everybody
I mean are you talking about negative
nails she was it she said can you help
me to understand I've only got about ten
minutes so I looked at her and one thing
I have learned I don't do counseling but
I talk with a lot of people who do in
psychologist psychiatry and the ministry
and they tell me that everybody who
comes to you with a problem are not
necessarily looking for a solution I
couldn't understand that for a long time
why do they bring you a problem if they
don't want to solve it well I can tell
you why they want to tell you about it
you about it you about you about it you
about and if you foul up the deal and
solve the problem they can tell you
again you again they want the attention
that goes with the problem and every
company just about it has that kind of
an individual they want the attention
that goes with griping and complaining
well I looked at the lady
and it wasn't unkindly but firmly I said
there yes and you know ma'am I'm afraid
your problem it's about to get worse she
said what do you mean I said I believe
they're gonna fire you
she was stunned I could have stunned him
or about hit her in the face with a
bucket of ice water
she said fire me why on earth would they
fire me
inflection and her voice clearly said
they're the bad guys I'm the good guy
why don't they fire them and keep me
have you ever noticed that people who
are the problem never recognize that
they are they're in complete denial they
think denial is just a river in Egypt
why would they fire me yet I said ma'am
I don't believe there's a company in
America big enough to contain this much
poison in one small spot have you ever
noticed that when somebody's about to
lose something they've been complaining
about whether it's a car a home a mate a
job or whatever when all of a sudden it
appears they're gonna lose them it takes
on brand-new value so you look to me and
said well what can I do I said do you
really want to know she said yes I do
that's the reason I came to see you I
came looking for help but you sure have
been in a help so far
I said well ma'am I've got an idea and I
will absolutely guarantee you it
positively definitely absolutely will
work if you will just do it she said
I'll try anything within reason I said
okay when you get home tonight all of
your household tasks are complete it's
bedtime get off in a room right by
yourself get a sheet of paper out and at
the top of it right I like my job
because he interrupted me she said
that'll be easy I don't like nothing
about that job don't like nothing about
those people down there and I said well
just as a matter of curiosity do you
work there for benevolent reasons or do
they pay you for working there she said
well I got to confess they pay me and I
said you don't like to be paid oh she
said yes I do I said okay tell you what
you do open your notebook right now
we'll start our list of the things you
like about your dog they pay you for
working there and you do like it don't
you said absolutely but she just stood
there I said no open your notebook now
and we'll get busy on the list he just
stood there I said ma'am let me let me
tell you what my experience in life has
been I've discovered that in 100% of the
cases no
exceptions people who won't take step
number one never take step number two
you see she had come to me with an
impossible dream her dream was that nice
mr. Ziegler was going to solve all of
her problems and she would live happily
ever after but folks I Got News for you
I can't solve her problems I can't solve
your problems but I will give you some
steps that are absolutely definitely and
positively will work for you as it
worked
eventually for her I said well ma'am let
me tell you something unless you're
willing to take step number one right
now it's been nice talking with you she
angrily opened her notebook before we
got through there were 22 things she
liked about her job now I wanted it not
only did they pay her for working there
that they paid her above average she had
three weeks vacation with pay she had a
retirement program she was a non-profit
Sharon she had health insurance life
insurance and accident insurance
she lived less than ten minutes from
home she was in no management decisions
that come to senator three seminars a
year to be paid for chat her own private
office and party play twenty two things
that she liked about her job now I said
man when you get home tonight everything
is finished get off in a room right by
yourself
close the doors change one word from I
like my job to I love my job
get in front of that mirror and folks I
cannot say this strongly enough but I'm
going to try the eyes are the windows of
the soul look yourself in that and with
excitement and enthusiasm say I love my
job because they pay me for working
there I love my job because they pay me
above average were working there I love
my job because they have a wonderful
insurance program I love my job before
every one of the statements you would
sleep better that night you see there's
something hidden in what I'm saying to
you now when she says I like my jobs is
really saying I'm grateful for my job
and of all of the emotions we can have
according to Ann's
Celje the number one stress pessimist in
America
the healthiest of all human emotions is
Greta to you I said you go down that
list I like my job I love my job rather
that is a way of gratitude you'll sleep
better the first night tomorrow morning
when you get up get back in front of the
mirror just before you go to work get
back in front of the mirror and repeat
the process again with excitement and
enthusiasm I love my job because and
take the list with you because the
reality is you see you will have started
to change from a fault finder to a good
finder some people do really find fault
like there's a reward for it they really
do take the list with you and you will
be able to add to that list absolutely
guaranteed do this every morning and
every night and you will have an
astonishing recovery from this advanced
case of stinking thinking now I didn't
say that to her but I'm saying it to you
that's what it was it was an advanced
case of stinking thinking what six weeks
later I was back in Birmingham Alabama I
was doing a follow up sales seminar now
the lady was not in sales but she had
been listening to my tapes he had been
listening to automobile university and
seeing discovered that everybody sells
everybody will ever hear this is in
selling whether you're a school teacher
a civil service worker military
personnel an executive secretary doesn't
make it a difference what you do you
sell every day of your life there she
was on that at the sales seminar seated
on the front row
grinning so wide she could have eaten a
banana sideways I'm telling you you're
talking about somebody that was excited
she was turned on I said well how you
done see grant even more broadly and
said mr. Ziegler I'm doing wonderfully
well and thank you for asking
she said you cannot believe how much
those people down there have changed
I got a lid on the line folks you're not
going to change anybody else did you
change you everything really does begin
with you now you see the unfortunate
thing this lady had been raised in a
very negative environment first her
parents had told her that should never
amount to anything they said you know
you're always late to always sloppy why
can't you be like your brother or your
sister or whatever when she got married
her husband had continued it and so her
self-talk had become completely negative
everything is he said about herself was
negative I you know like dad said I'm
never about anything like my husband
says I can't do anything right but when
she started changing the input then some
radical changes took close and these top
10 principles that I have put together
here for this program you might want to
jot down you might want to go into your
desk and just take out a little piece of
paper but I think if you practice them
and look at them and see them they come
from someone who's had a burning desire
but has also been living a life in which
I have felt independent of the opinions
of others in terms of whether or not I
should or shouldn't be doing that
there's something that I allow to
consult myself within myself rather than
looking outside to see if this is right
or not and so let me just kind of I'll
number them and I'll go through them and
I'll give you some examples of them and
you decide whether they're to your
liking or whether they work or not
the first of these principles came from
a Vedanta scholar on the in the 10th
century
his name was till oppa it's uh it's not
exactly bestseller books but it's the
kind of thing that really excites me
because I think of going back a thousand
years or 2,000 years and reading what
some of the greatest minds had to say
and how open they were to the
potentiality that each and every one of
us have for greatness and this first
principle says
as tell oppa put it have a mind that is
open to everything and attached to
nothing one of the central principles of
my life is that no one knows enough to
be a pessimist about anything and that
each and every one of us when we close
our mind to what is possible for us or
what is possible for Humanity closes off
the genius that resides and lives in
each and every one of us having an open
mind doesn't necessarily mean finding
fault with all of the things that you've
been taught by others it means opening
yourself up to the potentiality and the
possibility that anything and everything
is possible so having a mind that is
open to everything and attached to
nothing really means finding within
ourselves the ability to get rid of a
trait that I find so common in
contemporary in the contemporary world
do you know that most people that I meet
spend their lives looking for occasions
to be offended they actually are out
there hoping that they can find some
reason to be offended and there's no
shortage of reasons they're out there
everywhere the way this person dressed
what the worst person said they turn on
their TV they hear the news they're
offended by this
someone didn't someone use language that
they didn't like someone doesn't share
the same customs at you and people
all day long in fact if you keep track
tomorrow you will find probably a
hundred reasons that you can go around
being offended but a mind that is open
to everything and attached to nothing is
a mind that says I'm never looking for
anything to be offended by and that
whatever anybody else out there has to
say my response to that is that's an
interesting point of view
I've never considered that before I
remember being interviewed for a morning
television show and the woman that was
interviewing me said how does it feel to
be talking to audiences where people
have all of these strange beliefs these
weird things that they come to and it it
intrigues me because one of the one of
the things that that Emerson said is in
one of his very first essays he says the
first thing we have to say respecting
what are called new views here in New
England where we are right now is that
they are not new but the very oldest of
thoughts cast into the mold of these new
times and that was in 1842 he was
speaking about that and this woman asked
me the question she said doesn't it
offend you that there's out there's
people out there and they're talking
about people using crystals to heal
somebody and I remember my response my
response was that if I've got
hemorrhoids and somebody out there is
convinced to me that crystals are gonna
heal them I'm ordering crystal chairs
I'm why not I mean all you have to do is
understand something called a placebo
and what is a placebo it's nothing more
than a convincing belief if I hand you
this pill and say this bill is going to
cure your arthritis and you take it and
the pill is just a sugar pill but your
arthritis disappears I'm into buying
those placebos where can I get some of
those placebos and it's true of
everything and it's when you think about
all the things that we enjoy and what
our life is like it took people who had
a mind that wasn't closed to allow us to
make the progress that we've made
progress is import is impossible if you
always do things the way you've always
done things but the other word in this
what talofa said is be attached nowhere
be attached Noah attachment really means
I am deluding
myself into a belief that if I can't
have or if I can't do this or that thing
then somehow I'm going to become
immobilized so an open mind that is
detached in one of in my most recent
book in a spiritual solution to every
problem I have a an observation and it's
an observation from Anthony de Mello men
I respect enormous ly a priest who in
the way to love puts it this way here's
a great test for your relationships
especially the relationships that you're
in with those whom you love not your
children but your spouses and your
lovers and and so on try this test on
for size one I am not really attached to
you at all I am merely deluding myself
into the belief that without you I will
not be happy and to and here's the
toughest test for non attachment I leave
you free to be yourself to think your
thoughts indulge your tastes follow your
inclinations behave in ways that you
decide are to your liking how's that for
a challenge and so what most of us do in
our relationships and why they are not
as successful as we would like them to
be is that we become attached and we
tell ourselves that this person behaves
in a way that I find offensive
then I can't be happy I make my
happiness my fulfillment dependent upon
those people that I love being what I
think that they should be and detachment
doesn't mean being a victim it just
simply means I know that I can make my
life fulfilled and happy by having a
mind that is open to everything and
attached nowhere
the second principle is a very simple
principle it says you can't give away
what you don't have now it sounds
ridiculous okay but it's more than what
meets the ear as you hear this you can't
give away what you don't have people who
are not good at giving away love can't
give away love because they don't have
it to give away if I want to give you a
dozen oranges I can't give you those
dozen oranges unless I go out and pick
up 12 oranges someplace otherwise all it
is is just empty rhetoric and the same
thing is true of virtually everything in
your life you can't give away in love
for others if you don't have love in
here to give away if what you have in
here is contempt if what you have in
here is anger if you haven't here is
fear then these are the things you're
going to be giving away in your life and
I've often thought and I really believe
very strongly that there's a law sort of
a law in the universe I call it the law
of attraction and the law of attraction
is one that works like this you get back
from the universe from the world what it
is that you put out there in the world
and if you're putting out there into the
world that I am not worthy of attracting
something beautiful into my life that
the universe will respond back to you
with exactly that message and there are
people who come to me and who came to me
for years when I had my own counseling
practice and so on and they would say to
me I just keep attracting the same kind
of people the same kind of events the
same kind of losers into my life why is
that why do I keep doing it I keep
attracting an absence of of abundance I
just can't seem to attract abundance
into my life I'm always behind the eight
ball I'm never getting ahead and I
suggested them I said
ever occur to you that that's the very
kind of message you're sending out to
the world and out to the universe that
the ocean of abundance is there and you
can go to that ocean of abundance and
you can take a Mack truck and you can
fill it up twenty times a day and take
it out of there and guess what it
doesn't impact at all the ocean of
abundance it doesn't even go down a
zillion of an inch it's unlimited or you
can go to the same ocean of abundance
with a eyedropper and you can just take
this much out once a month and say
that's all that seems to be available
for me and the interesting thing for me
is that when people go to this ocean of
abundance this unlimited world all that
I have is line it says in the holy books
all that I have is nine it's all there
for you but if you believe inside that
it's limited that you can only get so
much that other people are going to get
it before you do then you'll find
yourself creating that very same thing
and the even more interesting part about
this you can't give away what you don't
have principle is that if your message
to the universe is gimme-gimme-gimme
which is a lot of people's message to
the universe I want this from you I want
that from you please give me this I have
to have that that's what their prayer is
like that's what their message isn't you
know and they say I want this from the
universe give me give me give me the
universe's response back to that kind of
an mentality is exactly the same the
universe will say right back to you over
and over again gimme gimme gimme and
you'll find yourself never ever arriving
but always being in a state of striving
always feeling as if you're being
neglected never feeling as if you have
enough always feeling as if you're being
shortchanged because you're constantly
under the pressure to give to get back
what the universe is demanding from you
and the interesting thing about all of
this the irony of this is that if you
shift that
and you say to the universe to the world
how may I serve how may I serve the
universe's response back to you is how
may I serve you how may I serve you and
it's very intriguing when you take your
energy and your attention off of what
you are demanding from the world and
instead saying what can I give to the
world and it's really the the basis
behind that very famous line of the
president John Kennedy's inaugural
address ask not what your country can
ask what you can do for your country
and the irony of that is and I've
learned that in my own life that when I
stopped thinking about what was in it
for Wayne Dyer and how much could I get
and I began to shift and say how can I
help you how can I give to you what can
I do for you and people who write to me
well I send them something when when I
encounter somebody that needs help of
some kind I'm very often just giving
that to them and then I find that it
just keeps coming back into my life
and once I shifted that energy off of
what can I have into what can I give it
seemed to me that the universe responded
back with the very same message what can
I give to you and the most incredible
and wonderful and beautiful abundance
has flowed into my life in every way
that I can possibly think of you can't
give away what you don't have so take a
look at an inventory of what you do have
how much do you love yourself how much
kindness do you have in you how much
peace do you have in you how much joy do
you have in you and if you're able to
give that away as many times as you can
in a given day watch and see how much
more of that continues to show up and
come back in your life okay the third
principle is one of my very favorites
it's called there are no justified
resentments and this is a very difficult
principle for many people to get but
that I believe very strongly in I was in
a group one time of drug addicts and
alcoholics and I was one of the people
that was a sponsor and leading this
group and the sign on the wall said
there are no justified resentments in
this group and what I said to that group
that that night was no matter what
anybody says to you here no matter what
kind of anger comes directed towards you
no matter how much hate you may
encounter showing up in your life there
are no justified resentments meaning
that if you carry around resentment
inside of you about anything or about
anyone and I'm talking about the person
that you lent money to and hasn't paid
you back I'm talking about the person in
your life that you feel was abusive in
your life I'm talking about the person
who walked out on you and left you for
somebody else I'm talking about all of
the things that you have justified in
your heart and in your life that you
have the right to be resentful about and
I'm suggesting to you that those
resentments will always end up harming
you and creating in you a sense of
despair I've often said that you know
one ever dies from a snake bite the
snake bite will never kill you
you cannot be unbidden once you're
bitten you're bitten but it's the venom
that continues to pour through your
system after the bite that will end up
destroying you so now you have to take a
look at all of the resentments that you
may have in your life and I'd like to
suggest to you that I think there is a
wonderful metaphor for this that I have
created
in my life for how to make this work and
I think that Regis Philbin is the one
who's responsible for it all right
my buddy Regis there's a show called Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire that has been
popular all over the world I were in
South Africa it comes on all right I was
in Australia and they've got their own
Australian version and in Greece they
have the Greek edition of Who Wants to
Be a Millionaire
and basically this show has two levels
that you have to get to now the first
level is the $1,000 level and at the
$1,000 level you basically have to
answer a question like on your hand you
have some digits those digits on your
hand are called your feet your nose your
ears your fingers oh and everybody who
ever goes on the show has this horrible
dread that they're gonna go out on one
of those questions right so basically in
order to get to the thousand dollar
level all you have to do is answer five
pretty simple simple questions in order
to to get to the thousand dollar level
now on this program the thousand dollar
level for you in this metaphor means
that you will leave with something if
you get this at least get this this is
the thousand dollar level you must send
blame out of your life for any
conditions of your life blame has to go
all right now blame means if you're
sitting there with a disease you say
without guilt it's mine I take
responsibility for it this means that if
you have been through any tough
circumstances in your life this means if
you have a minimal amount of financial
security in your life this means if your
children don't get along with you this
means that if your neighbors are having
taking up a petition to get you out of
the neighborhood
whatever it might be that's going on in
your life you name it and everybody
across the this great country across
this world has a series of these things
that you're willing to say I am here
because of the choices that I have made
right now I'm willing to say that even
though it's difficult and we know it's
really not your fault we know really
there's a lot of people out there who
are really bad alright but but you're
willing to say no blame that's the first
level all right that's where you
understand no justified resentment and
then and the who wants to be a
millionaire show there is what is called
the $32,000 level and the $32,000 level
is not only an opportunity for you to
walk away with a sizable amount of
goodies which you can walk away from
tonight in this program but it also is
the door opener to multi wealth but you
got to get to this in order to have an
opportunity to move into these
transcendent levels all right
millionaire spiritual status all right
you got to get through these next five
questions and this $32,000 question our
level rather comes to this it came to me
from a quotation that I used in the
writing of a spiritual solution to every
problem
I read the a book that was written a
couple of thousand years ago by
Patanjali the Yoga Sutras the aphorisms
of Patanjali and one of those sutures
one of those aphorisms observations that
this brilliant man made almost two
thousand years ago was this
he said if you become steadfast in your
abstentions of thoughts of harm directed
towards others all living creatures will
cease to feel enmity in your presence
now this translates to blame pretty
basic no more blame I'm just not going
to assign responsibility to other people
for where I am because now I have an
opportunity to get rid of it if I think
someone else caused it
then I've got to wait for somebody else
to change in order for me to get rid of
it and you might wait forever for that
but if I take responsibility for it I
can do something including move on which
might be the most important thing to do
but at the higher level when there are
no justified resentments what you are
doing is what st. Francis did Francesca
what you are doing is you are at a place
where you are sending love in response
to hate you are literally saying no
matter what comes my way I am going to
be steadfast in my abstention of
thoughts of harm directed toward others
I'm going to work hard at no matter what
comes my way having it come out of me
what I want to come out of me and that
is love and that is a higher energy and
if you can get to that level
Patanjali said all living creatures will
cease to feel enmity in your presence I
have a little girl a precious little
girl I have six precious girls and two
precious sons but I have a little girl
who is almost 12 and she loves animals
like no one I've ever met in my life I
mean her whole life revolves around
animals and when we walk in the woods
butterflies avoid me fly away from
people around and they come and they
land right on her arm and it happens all
the time
all living creature she couldn't have a
thought of harm directed towards any
living creature and Patanjali said to us
all living creatures will cease to feel
fear or enmity or anger in the presence
of those who can send love in response
to hate that's when I mean when I say
there are no justified resentments
what I'd like to do I'd like to share a
little story here with you it's a very
tender story it was sent to me by
someone who sends me beautiful things in
the mail and I call it the teddy story
and I'd like to read this to you if I
can do it without tearing up and this
story illustrates this as well as
anything I've ever seen there's a story
many years ago of an elementary school
teacher her name was mrs. Thompson and
she stood in front of her fifth grade
class on the very first day of school
she told the children a lie like most
teachers she looked at her students and
said that she loved them all the same
but that was impossible because they're
in the front row slumped in his seat was
a little boy named Teddy Stoddard
mrs. Thompson had watched Teddy the year
before and noticed that he didn't play
well with the other children that his
clothes were messy and that he
constantly needed a bath Teddy could be
unpleasant
it got to the point where mrs. Thompson
would actually take delight in marking
his papers with a broad red pen and
making bold X's and then putting a big F
at the top of his papers at the school
where mrs. Thompson taught she was
required to review each child's past
records and she put Teddy's off until
last however when she reviewed his file
she was in for a surprise
Teddy's first-grade teacher wrote teddy
is a bright child with already laughs he
does his work neatly and he has good
manners he's a joy to be around
his second grade teacher wrote Teddy's
an excellent student well-liked by his
classmates but he's troubled because his
mother has a terminal illness and life
at home must be a struggle his third
grade teacher wrote his mother's death
has been hard on him he tries to do his
best but his father doesn't show much
interest and his home life will soon
affect him if steps aren't taken
Teddy's fourth grade teacher wrote
Teddy's withdrawn and doesn't show up
much interest in school he doesn't have
many friends and sometimes
he even sleeps in class by now mrs.
Thompson realized the problem and she
was ashamed of herself she felt even
worse when her students brought her
Christmas presents wrapped in beautiful
ribbons and bright paper except for
Teddy's his president was clumsily
wrapped and hid heavy brown paper that
he got from the grocery bag mrs.
Thompson took pains to open it in the
middle of the other presence some of the
children started to laugh when she found
a rhinestone bracelet with some of the
stones missing and a bottle that was one
quarter full of perfume but she stifled
her children's laughter when she
exclaimed how pretty the bracelet was
putting it on and dabbing some of the
perfume on her wrist
Teddy Stoddard stayed after school that
day just long enough to say mrs.
Thompson today you smell just like my
mom used to after the children laughed
she cried for at least an hour on the
very day she quit teaching reading
writing and arithmetic and instead she
began to teach children mrs. Thompson
paid particular attention to teddy as
she worked with him and his mind seemed
to come alive the more she encouraged
him the faster he responded by the end
of the year teddy had become one of the
smartest children in the class and
despite her lie became one of her
teacher's pets
a year later she found a note under the
door from Teddy telling her that she was
still the best teacher he ever had in
his whole life six years went by before
she got another note from teddy
he then wrote that he had finished high
school third in his class and she was
still the best teacher he ever had in
his whole life for years after that she
got another letter saying that while
things had been tough at times he stayed
in school and stuck with it it would
soon graduate from college with the
highest of honors he assured mrs.
Thompson that she was still the very
best and favorite teacher he ever had in
his whole life then four more years
passed and yet another letter came this
time he explained that after he got his
bachelor's degree he decided to go a
little further the letter explained that
she was still the best and favorite
teacher he ever had but now his name was
a little long
the letter was signed Theodore F
Stoddard MD but the story doesn't end
there you see there was yet another
letter that spring Teddy said he'd met
this girl and was going to be married he
explained that his father had died a
couple of years ago and he was wondering
if mrs. Thompson might agree to sit in
the place at the wedding that was
usually reserved for the mother of the
groom of course mrs. Thompson did and
guess what she wore that bracelet the
one with several rhinestones missing and
she made sure she was wearing the
perfume that Teddy remembered his mother
wearing on their last Christmas together
they hugged each other and dr. Stoddard
whispered in mrs. Thompson's ear thank
you so much for making me feel important
and showing me that I could make a
difference
mrs. Thompson came with tears in her
eyes and whispered back Teddy you have
it all wrong you were the one who taught
me that I could make a difference I
didn't know how to teach until I met you
and that a beautiful story yeah
that symbolizes there are no justified
resentments work at reaching that
$32,000 level the place where the only
thing you have to send is love because
that's what's inside and that's the
message of our greatest spiritual
teachers that's all they ever had to
give away thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know what did you
think
should we keep this series going it's
one of the series that is a question
mark for us did you enjoy this format do
you want this series to live on or would
you rather we feel this timeslot with
something else and you have ideas for
that something else might be let me know
leave a comment below thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe or
whatever your one where it is and I'll
see you soon